i actually think they made a very smart  move because  obama's have to have their show on  spotify and spotify doesn't have to pay  them [ __ ]  they just have to be like what are you  talking i'm not going to pay you nothing  you're going to put it on here anyways  because you have to mess with my  audience okay  but the reason why we were willing to  pay rogan is because he agreed to be  what exclusive  if you're willing to do exclusive we'll  pay you 25 and you do one or two  episodes a week but if you want to be  able to put this everywhere why the hell  am i going to give you money i'm going  to give you [ __ ] and i think that's the  right move they made good for spotify